- [Gary Voiceover] Entrepreneurship
is hard and lonely.
If you look at the current
state of social media,
you would think that 98% of
the time in entrepreneurship,
it's sunny and rosey and fun,
when reality, it's the reverse.
The reality is most people
spend a lot of their times,
day in and day out in dark clouds,
not sunshine.
(thundering)
When you own your own business,
everything is your own fault.
You are basically in the business
of putting out negative fires.
Disproportionately our time is spent
in navigating or anticipating dark clouds.
(thundering)
It's not glamorous,
it's not getting the
accolades of self-ease
and being there,
it's not the big time meetings,
with the biggest companies in the world.
It's just hard core dirt.
(digital music)
And I think that anybody
that doesn't realize that
is not building an actually
successful business.
They're living in a fake environment
or they're naive and they
don't realize it's coming.
The percentage of
successful entrepreneurs,
ones that can make a living
and live their lives on their own back,
not in a company structure is quite low.
We're in the fire fighter business.
A person who lives their life everyday,
of anxiety of knowing they
are the last line of defense.
(thundering)
It's not glamorous, it's hard!
The sunshine's seductive, right?
It's why these people become losers.
I'm in L.A.
I'm going to ComplexCon.
I got my new K Swiss sneaker drop in,
and I'm doing a talk with
Karen Civil and Drama,
and a couple others, so
just rolling through L.A.
and then I'm taking a red-eye home.
- [Man] And you don't stop, dog.
You just going.
- [Woman] Hi Gary!
- Hello.
It's good to see you, man.
I'll see you in a little bit.
- [Man] How are you doing, bud?
- [Gary] What up!
- [Woman] Thank you so much.
- Everybody wanted to
be an astronaut one day.
Like, every kid that I'm looking at,
these good-looking kids,
they all wanted to be
astronauts and pilots in 1957.
'Cause that
- What do they want to be now?
- Entrepreneurs!
- Yeah.
- I mean, this is my moment.
And by the way, it'll be fun
and in nine years the world will melt.
Everybody will not be
an entrepreneur anymore.
It won't be cool.
They'll blame
entrepreneurship for the melt.
And I'll still be an entrepreneur.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause that's what
I've always been.
That's what I am now.
And that's what I'll
be to the last breath.
(digital music)
Turn that James,
- G.V.
- What's up my dude?
- What's up brother?
You good?
- I'm good yeah.
- It's nice to meet you,
- Nice to meet you,
- I'm Roderick, man.
Nice to meet you.
- It's a real pleasure, man.
- Bless on, man.
- Keep doing good things.
- See the boys in the swiss.
- Yeah, they're doing it!
I like the green makes me feel very Jets.
- 'Cause I'm a Jet, man.
- Very New York Jets.
Let's go baby.
- [Man] You got some lifestyle
- Gary, Gary, Gary
- [Gary] My dude.
I love that dude.
- I'm a big fan, bro.
- Thank you, dude.
- I've been trying to meet
you for like three years.
- [Gary] Yup.
- I'm messing with (mumbles)
The way I connected with him was,
through your DM advice
- Aha
- and all that.
- You've gotta be fulfilled
with your process,
not what you're trying to
get out of your process.
If you do something
trying to get something
out of your process,
you will always lose because
you're gonna be impatient.
You're like, "why don't
I have a phat watch,
"or a million followers yet."
Because that's the only
reason you're doing it.
When you do something
for the second thing,
not the thing.
You're always vulnerable
- [Man] My elbow.
- [Man] Pardon me, ya'll,
pardon me.
- [Woman] Hey!
- [Gary] Ray Klein.
- Hi, let me see ya.
- Good to see you, my dude.
- How you doing, man?
- How are you, man?
- Pleasure, pleasure.
- It's a real pleasure for me, man.
- Much love.
- Yeah, man.
Keep doing your thing, dude.
- We're getting
into the wine business.
- Yo, let me help!
- Yo.
- Yo, hit me up with that.
I can
- You're going to love
this move.
- I can really really help.
Hit me with that.
Seriously.
Hit me up, I'll help.
- Absolutely.
We got you.
- Great to see you, my dude.
You, too.
Hmm.
Hey, man, so good to see you!
- Man, how've you been?
- How you been?
- I got you, brother.
Good, man.
- Good man.
- Pleasure
- Real pleasure.
- (mumbles) everyday.
- Dude, good to see you.
(digital music)
(crowd cheering)
- A lot of people are
making $86,000 a year
at a job they hate,
imagine making $79,000 a year
selling something you love.
That doesn't mean that
you're going to own Ferraris
and 16 homes but happiness
needs to be the agenda.
(audience clapping)
3 to 6 p.m. I'll be downstairs.
- Okay, can I give you a ride
- Can I
- Gary,
- Gary, alright.
- Gary, can I obviously,
- Gary,
- Gary, alright
- [Female] Alright, it's enough.
- We really
- I gotta go.
Alright.
- This way,
- You got it.
I'm downstairs.
- Thanks a lot, Gary.
Give me a second.
- Real pleasure.
- What up, doc?
You were there?
- Of course.
- Awesome, man, thank you.
- I came here just for
- Gary, nice to see you,
- Good to see you.
How'd you like it?
- Oh, it was awesome.
- It was good?
- Yeah.
("Voodoo. Fight the power." By The Seige)
♪ Sorry, not sorry. ♪
♪ Pardon this army. ♪
♪ Young sees the new ♪
- How you living?
- How are you?
- You got any new musicians
we should look out for?
Any rappers?
- Lil Got It.
Lil Keyed.
I with those two heavy.
Heavy.
I love those two guys.
- It's pretty good.
- Ah, dude.
I'm really proud of you.
- Oh, I appreciate it.
- I like how you navigate
through adversity.
And I like how you're like,
keep building, building, building.
- Yeah, they can't stop us, Gary.
We didn't come this far to quit, bro.
- That's the truth.
♪ They ain't ready. ♪
♪ Ya'll. ♪
♪ They don't want you to win ♪
♪ Want you to win. ♪
♪ People dying in the streets ♪
- Evening, brother.
- Yeah, don't pass judgment on him.
He's your brother.
Spit knowledge to him.
So that he can think for himself.
But don't judge him.
♪ I see inner sin. ♪
♪ Sick of asking, ♪
♪ We 'bout to start blastin' ♪
♪ Sick of waitin' ♪
♪ We 'bout to start takin' ♪
♪ We occupy the spot ♪
♪ And leave that m ♪
♪ Fakin' ♪
♪ Fight the power. ♪
♪ Ignite the towers. ♪
- How do you get to the
point where you can take
how do you get to that mindset?
- [Gary Voiceover] To who?
- [Man Voiceover] To the world?
I mean nobody can say it,
not my parents, just everyone.
- Got it.
By just recognizing that
it's the place of ultimate strength.
By like just really talking
to yourself everyday
- Yeah.
- and not
over-judging yourself.
By realizing that
that gives you the biggest
chance to happiness.
The reason I didn't care of being 29
in my dad's liquor store packing boxes,
not having any money.
- Yeah.
- Was 'cause I didn't care
what anybody thought of me.
- Fair enough.
- I practiced.
- Practiced.
- I practiced it.
- Alright, I hear ya.
- You understand?
- Appreciate it, man.
- [Man] We gotta roll.
- [Gary] Alright, let's go.
- Have a good one,
- [Gary] Guys, I'll see
you later.
Cool.
- [Man] Hi, guys.
- [Man] Sir,
- [Man] How are you, sir?
- Guys it looks great.
- Podcast.
- Thanks, Gary.
(upbeat digital music)
- Wanted to say hi to you.
- You're too heavy, man.
- I
- Talk, really good idea
- What up?
- [Woman] Oh my God, Gary V!
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
Can I take a picture with you guys?
(upbeat digital music)
- You're a good man.
- Thank you.
- What up, baby?
- Videos,
- Thank you, my dude.
- Every morning, man
- You helped me through a lot, man.
- The key to the next step
is whatever is on my mind
at that moment that makes me happy.
100,000%
Of course.
Thank you, fellas.
What up, my dog?
- How are you?
- Complex Con is a physical manifestation
of the current state of the culture.
Like, this is,
this is the current version
of the baseball card shows
I did when I was 14.
The flipping mentality,
people want to kill each
other just to get that thing,
to make a couple bucks.
Or to get the fresh stuff,
it's just
it's the pulse of the
reality of the youth.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome, man.
What's your name?
- Dominick.
- Nice to meet you, bro.
You look real fresh, bro.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, man, you having a good time?
- Yeah.
- You like Wu Tang Clan?
Thanks, man.
Take care.
- The number one reason people fail.
- Entitlement.
- Yeah.
- Lack of self-awareness.
- Right.
- And number one,
making excuses which come
from the first two things.
- In 2013 you sent me coffee at Limp.
Via Twitter, do you remember that?
- I do remember that.
- Dude.
- That's amazing.
- [Gary] Complex Con.
I Love you, for the culture.
- [Woman] Thank you, so much.
- [Gary] Hi, Tara.
How are you?
Good to see you!
- Yeah, you, too, you are!
- That whole crew, it's amazing man.
Proud of you.
- [Gary] Finally, my dog.
- Finally, bro.
- Finally.
- I see you everyday, buddy, though.
- You, too, my dude, I got
so much love for you, man.
I'm so proud of you.
- Thank you, man, I appreciate you, man.
- You keep doing, man.
We need to sit down and
have dinner for real.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- You doing well?
How's it been going?
- Amazing, bro.
We just landed but I'm so grateful, bro.
- How long are you in town?
- I'm leaving on Monday.
- Have a nice week.
- Yeah, whenever I'm here
staying here at Long beach.
- I love you, guys.
I love you.
- How are you, bro?
- So good man.
- Bro.
- It's always a pleasure.
You know I always see what you do.
- I see it.
I see it.
Same man, I love everything, man.
I got you, 24/7.
- Thank you.
I'mma see you at the end and
give me your phone number.
- Okay.
- Thank you, my dear.
- Bye, guys, have a good time.
How are you?
- Thank you, good.
- Oh my God.
- I'm glad you're here.
- [Man] V, One last pic?
- [Gary] Let's go.
- Big fan, man, great concert.
- Thank you, bro, take care.
There you have it, Complex Con.
We came through hard,
and we did it.
Saw the culture, tasted it.
Brought as much value as I could.
Loved it.
We love you, Complex Con.
We'll see you next year.
- Hi, what's up, man,
- 'Sup, man.
- Can I take a picture?
- Yeah, real quick.
- [Gary Voiceover] If you're
a pure-bred entrepreneur,
you love the dark clouds.
You understand that the
fake entrepreneurship era
we live through loves the sunshine.
When it's good, and happy and easy.
But if it's in your DNA.
If you actually are an entrepreneur.
You know exactly why the
upcoming era of dark clouds,
is going to be very important.
Because at the end of the day,
this is a game based on merit.
And if you don't know how
to navigate those storms,
you can't be an all-time entrepreneur.
(thundering)
I love the dark clouds,
because they're part of the process.
(calming music)